it is six months since police
killed brianna taylor in her own home
but despite
public outrage there's been strikingly
few developments
until now a 12 million dollar settlement
reached
for the wrongful death lawsuit brought
by her family
and while her death was a tragedy for so
many
let's remember that brianna was first a
daughter a sister
a granddaughter a niece a girlfriend
a friend and a co-worker and for those
who knew her
the pain is visceral and the loss ever
more
devastating the emergency room
technician died
minutes after a drug raid at her
apartment
she'd been shot eight times
her name became a rallying cry against
police brutality
with celebrities and politicians also
calling for accountability
brianna taylor brianna taylor
city officials have now agreed to
policing reforms
we will now require a commanding officer
to review and approve
all search warrants affidavits in
support of search warrants
and risk matrices before an officer
seeks judicial approval
for the warrant we're create we're
creating a clear command structure when
executing warrants
at multiple locations but the three
officers involved have not been charged
and for briana's family
the fight is far from over
as significant as today is it's only the
beginning of getting full
justice for brianna we must not lose
focus on what the real drive is
and with that being said it's time to
move forward
with the criminal charges because she
deserves that
and much more
her beautiful spirit and personality
is working through all of us on the
ground so please continue
to say her name brianna tyler
this is a mother still grieving visiting
her daughter's memorial
as she awaits an investigation by the
state attorney general
unable to find peace without
prosecutions
cordille sky news washington